[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنها قد تبدو جميعها متشابهة ، إلا أن
المياه المعبأة في زجاجات هي نفسها المصطلحات مثل
مياه الينابيع النقية والارتوازية تشير إلى حالة المياه قبل أن
تأتي مياه الينابيع المعبأة من مصدر تحت الأرض
ويجب جمعها في
النبع قبل معالجتها وتعبئتها
المياه النقية  يمكن أن تأتي من أي مصدر
ولكن يجب معالجتها بشكل كبير مثل المياه
المقطرة أو منزوعة الأيونات قبل
تسميتها بالمياه المعدنية النقية فهي
تختلف عن الأنواع الأخرى بسبب
المستوى الثابت من المعادن
والعناصر التي لا تحتوي على أي شيء إضافي
يمكن إضافتها إليها كما في حالة الارتوازية التي
تشير إلى الماء  من بئر ينقر على
طبقة معينة من الصخور أو الرمال
التي تتدفق المياه من خلالها ويتم تخزينها ،
لا يزال البحث خارجًا عن
النوع الأفضل لصحتك ، لكن
أهم الوجبات الجاهزة هي التأكد من
أنك تشرب كمية كافية من الماء أيهما
النوع الذي تختاره للنساء
يوصي الخبراء بشرب حوالي 11 كوبًا يوميًا
وأكثر بقليل من 15 كوبًا للرجال